first of all congratulations on the
movie uh it's a great sequel i know fans
are going to love it um and that's all i
have so i will see you guys here steve
love you to hang out
oh my god steve he doesn't shut up about
cyclops do you have a stop do you have a
cyclops figure behind you
there's no cyclops figure behind me
they're sold out they're probably sold
out is that why i mean i definitely
think it's because they're sold out
what's funny is i get this [ __ ] from
from all the actors that have had a toy
made if i don't have the toy behind me
well we are we are an automatic bike i
can't see do you have my character from
house of lies back there do you have a
clyde overhaul back there steve or no
i'm waiting on the after party figure
okay you're getting that green jacket uh
jasper i almost called my character the
wrong name yes
can't wait for james to see it by the
way steve hasn't seen it it doesn't
support me as a person i can't believe
i'm like a normal human being if i see
all his work i'm gonna be two stars i
saw all the x-men movies
okay yeah i yeah i see where this is
going i want to get into sonic i will
just say the after party is phenomenal
and i really recommend it it's real good
the after party to what oh my goodness a
show i'm going to show you oh right now
yes i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
steve we're wasting your time
i'm so sorry this is so off the rails so
listen uh i think that the sequel is
just it's bigger and better and i think
that audiences are going to totally
respond what are each of you most
excited for audiences to see in it
i'm excited that they get a couple new
characters i'm excited to see
uh their reaction when when tails and
knuckles come into the picture and and
it's not just sonic and how he sort of
you know because we the first film it's
all about like he feels pretty isolated
and and finds tom and they have the
friendship and we bring him into the
into our home and we become this happy
family and now he's going to be a little
older and wanting to stretch his legs a
bit and sneak out of the house and you
know he's getting a little cagey i guess
you could say and uh
and um he wants some uh some some bonds
and some friendships outside like like a
normal kid like outside of just his
parents so it's uh i'm excited for the
audience to see um how that relationship
uh starts and continues with tails and
knuckles and it's cool to bring some of
them you know more of the characters
from the video game into the movie yeah
i'm excited there's the cat perfect
timing i'm super excited for these big
action sequences and the idea that we're
bringing some of these levels from the
games in there and obviously we have all
these references also people are going
to be so psyched with like adam pally
has a wonderful role in this one natasha
rothwell is an action star and it's like
lee is amazing in it and jim carrey is
incredible but i really love how once we
go off like once the movie is like once
once we set off on this adventure it
does not stop it is action set piece
after set piece and i think it holds its
own with some of these really cool like
you know marvel type movies and stuff
like that so i'm really proud that i
feel like we deliver on the idea of a
sequel being bigger and more epic
yeah i think that also uh i don't know
if jeff's gonna get enough credit for
what he does with this movie because
it's really hard to pull off what he's
done and make a bigger and better sequel
to something that you know audiences
already loved you know raising the
stakes is hard you know
can you sort of talk about maybe a
little bit of you know just working with
jeff and what do you think what does he
bring to the table that makes it such a
good movie yeah yeah well you're right
and that sequels and you know the
sophomore efforts are always harder
because you don't you lose the element
of surprise right first time around it
was you know we had a little bit of
element of element of surprise but
you know the sonic had its giant fan
base that we wanted to you wanted to
make them happy obviously but like once
you once you kind of
get the first one in the books and
everyone's happy with it yes great you
feel a little more confident a little
more comfortable going the second time
around but now there's an expectation
bar you know you definitely feel that
but you can also punch those buttons
that you know work as well and pull
those levers they're like okay they're
going to want to see this they're going
to see new characters coming in from the
game um but really it's like speaking to
jeff specifically you know he was one of
the biggest voices first time around
about like we need to listen to the fans
we want to give them what they want to
see but still have the sort of creative
license to make the movie we want to
make but it's not lost on him how
important that is that the audience you
know
should never be pandered to you know we
shouldn't just you know uh make a movie
for kids and forget about the adults um
he he loves the fans and we all love the
fans and we want everyone to be happy
but also thinking about like hey you
know maybe there's still people out
there who don't know about the sonic
game and who this character is and we
want to make the movie for them as well
so you know he's he's a great sort of
captain of that ship to sort of navigate
those waters because it is like you do
feel the expectations to deliver in a
bigger and better way
um but i feel like i feel confident that
we've you know with jeff sort of at the
helm that we're always going to be you
know putting the right foot forward i
think also if you think about one of the
most unique things and incredible things
about jeff is he directs a live action
movie then he comes and he directs me as
a voiceover artist he's directing
colleen in a different day on a
different room
yeah and he's directing idris also and
then he directs all of the final looks
for all the vfx things so he is doing so
much that it's
it's like incredible that it is cohesive
and it works perfectly together because
he really does have so much to juggle uh
it is incredible and you think about it
it's his second film it's it's
remarkable what he's capable of i think
he's gonna have an amazing future you
know whether it's making 20 more of
these or doing 100 other things whatever
he wants he's a special dude he'll have
a busy
future for sure
on that note i got to stop seriously
congrats and it really is going to be a
huge hit oh thank you thank you brother
good to see you a lot thank you later